we've decided to find people to try and
make our budget break even so in the
past we have we contract the service out
so each call out costs the rate payer
money and we're spending about 80
thousand dollars a year on the service
other councils have made use of
infringement and fines to recoup that
money so we've just started to do that
and we hope that we can break even and
we're going to be targeting those people
that what we call presidio offenders
that continually cause noise and
distress to the community so though they
will be the ones that we will be will be
targeting we're talking about noise from
residential areas mainly music would be
that those comment load music I don't
think people realize that that includes
the sauce so if you've got a cell phone
or an iPod or an iPad that is the source
that's connected to the stereo that
whole thing that will be seized in even
a TV if that is being played through the
TV so people seem to think it's just a
stereo but it's the source which
nowadays is often a phone or an iPad or
something so that that will that will be
seized so that that service now runs 24
hours a day and in addition to that we
also service will check out barking dog
complaints after hours the process works
by we get a call for obsessive noise and
there the contractor will go out and if
they determine excessive noise they can
issue it excessive noise Direction
matters they can also sees the equipment
of that stage if we get a second plate
within 72 hours we're going to give them
a fine of five hundred dollars and then
if we get a third complained at within
the six month period they get another
fine of seven hundred and fifty dollars
and to get their equipment back will
cost them $65 so if a noise source or
equipment is not claimed after six
months then we we have the right to to
sell out through auction or trade me or
whatever we've got other partners
involved in this and we've worked very
closely with them so first one is amagad
the contractor in that quite experienced
in doing especially another bigger
30 so we're learning getting the
learnings from there also the local
police though they will help us that
they will be attending most complaints
especially your assistance is required
but we are using that they're the two
ones that we're going to use to try and
really clamp down especially those
recipients offenders a goal here is to
reduce out that the cost to the rape are
that noisy parties calls us and we want
to put the cost back on to the people
that make the noise so yeah we're here
to reduce our rates and put the the cost
on the people that make the noise and if
that means seizing their equipment in
finding that that's that's the tools
that we'll be using to to ensure that
the rape part is not funding the service